welcome I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation and I'm joining you live from
the unfortunately clothes to interval
for this one we actually filmed it here
at the interval but it was great to work
with a small socially distance crew to
be filming here and I and I hope that
the recording kind of gives it a
different feel than than something that
was just being recorded in one of our
living rooms so we budget brought us a
few scenes of that recording and like
the last talk we actually recorded this
a few weeks ago that give us a chance to
edit it all together but Brian our
speaker tonight will be joining us for a
live Q&A as well as Kevin Kelly from
from our board tonight speaker is Bryan
Fischer he's an entomologist who's been
working for many decades in the field
and has identified as specializes in
ants and has identified over a thousand
ant species and is one of the greatest
storytellers I know and adventures that
I know and I've always loved his stories
he specifically has been working in
Madagascar for over 30 years where he's
gotten to know the local community and
realized that the the challenges they
have facing them in bringing protein
both to their diets as well as for for
selling have also challenged the
environment and tonight he's going to be
talking about really where his work in
entomology and this need for protein
come together in Madagascar
welcome Brian Thank You Xander it's
great to be here at the interval I first
want to start with is a love of ants I
must admit I never knew I was going to
study ants in fact my kind of gateway
into all this world was was simply
wanting to be outside as a kid I wanted
to be outside I knew I had to be outside
for the rest of my life and I thought oh
I want to be an explorer and be a
scientist and study botany in fact that
plants was what I wanted to study and
when I went to the tropics all I saw it
was ants and I was like who studies
these they should study these and people
said not too many people know anything
about ends so I switched right then drop
the B and the L and stuck with ants
until now now for most of you and sand
all insects are invisible but actually
they're the glue that holds systems
together they're the glue that hold
force together without insects we can't
talk about preserving forests but it's
those insects that brought me to
Madagascar now when you say Madagascar
and what do you think of it's on your
bucket list replication it's that's
unique place to go and discover the
wildlife the beauty now behind
Madagascar is an incredible story of
geographic isolation incredible
biodiversity but just opposed to all
that 50% of the children are
malnourished it's one of the few
countries that has an increasing area of
poverty where 90% of the people earn
less than $2 a day
and at the same time you have 10% of the
natural habitat left that means the
current system that's handling
population growth is going to break
you can't put more cattle on degraded
land
you can't cut down more forests to grow
corn if there's no more forests but well
I went to Madagascar it's the same
reason you would want to go to
Madagascar and that is for the wildlife
I went there to discover the insects and
to me it has been the best incredible
dream for the last 25 years exploring
all over Madagascar now when you think
expedition adventure maybe this is what
you think of you're just floating down
this beautiful jungle and off to your
right and left or just new species to
discover but a Madagascar it's much more
challenging in fact we spend most of our
time just get into the forest and for me
that's really been how I got to know
Madagascar you know I would use Google
Earth maps to find that remote forest
and then find out how to get there but
to get there requires enormous
cooperation from everybody we would only
do our work in the rainy season which
meant working and driving and
in places that were not supposed to be
able to get to in the rainy season but
we would take our trusty landcruiser and
off would go and it required village
after village after village of people to
help us and working with those people
and finally getting into the forest was
how I began to fall in love with
Madagascar and this was an incredible
privilege to go into these forest be the
first one there and in your backyard you
have all these incredible insects to
discover and at the same time you're
training people that have never been to
this forest this incredible world of
insects now my specialty is ants and
believe me we have made great
discoveries we have discovered or a
thousand new species of ants in
Madagascar
like this one shown here the hero ant a
new genus only found in Madagascar in
which these ants to protect their home
from an invader when the invader comes
and gets on that lip of clay it jumps
off and grabs him and jumps off and
keeping that predator away from their
nest which is only found on clay banks
we also established traps all across
Madagascar in fact right now we have 50
let's call them a lace trap which
catches flying insects so that we can
monitor them why is because we want to
create a system like a Dow Jones Indexes
an environment in which we can monitor
in real-time our impact and changes that
are happening that index will give us a
glimpse of what's happening to this glue
the insects that are holding force
together we need to understand our
impact on forests and we can do that by
looking at the insects now you may have
heard about this incredible decline of
insects the insect apocalypse well we
don't even know if that's really
happening because we don't have the
monitoring systems in place but a system
like this allows us to actually learn
something but with insects you got to be
ready there's a lot of them and our
traps catch a lot of insects that meant
we had a train an enormous group of
people and thanks to the generosity of
the Bay Area and the California Academy
of Sciences we've built a beautiful
center of research that includes a
dedicated staff for the study of insects
and it's with this team we've explored
over 400 places across
Madagascar for insects and over those
years I've gone back to beautiful sites
and been confronted with this and it
made me wonder what I was doing to help
save the forest and I began to wonder if
in 50 years are we gonna have any forest
left in Madagascar and without forests
what does that mean for all the people
I've worked with all the people I've
gotten to know and care about population
has doubled since the time I started
working in Madagascar what does that
mean for the future now that's a problem
that the world has to come to terms with
it's not just from Madagascar but we
have extended our self well beyond our
normal means for using landscapes so I
began to think I need to change as an
entomologist there's a role I can play
and it has to happen quick and I began
to think about the people and the
landscapes I realize I have to stop
working just in those pristine little
dots and begin to work with the people
that live around those forests and it
comes down to how are they gonna feed
their kids if they can't access the
forest if they can't cut down the trees
to grow new crops if they can't hunt for
bush meat and kill the lemurs how are
they gonna feed their kids they're
running out of options there's already
migration where people are moving and
looking for new possibilities and there
are none that men coming up with a new
solution and I call that the breakfast
before conservation
now his entomologist at first I thought
I had no role to play in this but then I
just started looking around I was kind
of blind to this but you see it those
are insects there in Madagascar they eat
edible insects
now insects you may have heard about
this now that more and more people are
turning to insects for lots of reasons
in fact it just makes sense
insects unlike warm-blooded animals like
a cow or a pig you don't have to waste
energy on heating a body you don't have
to give it extra water so I can sweat
looking at in terms of gains for insects
um compared to cattle where it takes
like 2,000 gallons of water to get a
pound of protein compared to only like
50 gallons of for a cricket protein
also in terms of space and its impact on
co2 take six times the feed to get a
pound from a cow compared to a cricket
for example so that simple conversion
rate even if you're feeding it the same
thing you'll get six times the protein
if you're feeding it to an insect
compared to cattle in fact studies have
shown that you can absorb more
micronutrients from eating insects than
slab of steak so you have efficient
conversion rates you have more
micronutrients and more studies are now
showing that improves our microbiome if
you eat insects so it just makes sense
so I wanted to see if there was
potential of building on that tradition
in Madagascar and finding maybe
potential native species in which we
could actually farm so to begin that
going through the history of the last
400 years and reading about what people
ate before and get digging up recipes
and documenting it and there's some
really interesting discoveries there in
fact the first insect mentioned in 1658
was this cicada called a flat it in fact
didn't even know it wasn't so cute alike
they called it a butterfly then they
call that an ant but actually this
insect the red ones there that looked
like flowers they tap into phloem and
actually exude a bunch of sugar because
they have to look for micronutrients in
the phloem inside the plant so they
create these fits sized piles of sugar
that the locals would gather up and eat
so would the lemurs - but this was
highly sought-after in fact during the
colonial period a french botanist
actually tried to farm these and create
this mana he called in madagascar using
this incredible planet but the real star
of this group of insects is what's
called the secondary the moment the
strange kind of harness on its head
there now these are amazing and this is
the other most talked about insect in
this group in the literature because
everybody loved to eat it it tastes like
bacon the locals call it the country but
in English you can call it the bacon bug
like bacon you can just put it in a pot
and fry it up in a
Griese and it's delicious going back and
reading through the history we also
discovered that one group of insects was
the most easily absorbed in other types
of cuisines and that was the pupae from
silk moths French chefs in Madagascar
would actually serve it in the French
residence in 1884 and they would
describe it as some butterfly brains
because it tasted like veal brains and
even the last queen of Madagascar used
to have special helpers that would scour
the countryside for these types of
edible insects including the silk moth
pupa and also locust and to my surprise
I didn't see this before just next to
our Center in the capital of Madagascar
they sell pupae of silk moths and do
note that they are selling it next just
shrunk which is actually also a
crustacean so it's actually
phylogenetically the correct place to
sell it in the market and it's actually
sold at the same price as shrimp in
other words historically they valued
edible insects there that sold at a very
high price and there's a long tradition
of it but one insect is actually more
like a staple and that is the locust now
when you see a locust swarm or hear
about it you may already be so biased
that you think oh my god this is
terrible
which to me as an entomologist I want to
question that behavior because when we
look at like a South Sea Island Philip
penguins or in the Serengeti a
wildebeest migration we think of
something actually wow the abundance of
nature but the abundance of nature when
it comes to insects actually should be
looked at in a different way - now the
locust has been recorded as something
that supersedes everything if a swarm
comes in fact an early Explorer
documented when there was a war going on
that after 10 days of battle a locusts
swarm arrived and all the soldiers
stopped to gather up the locust all the
villages which were hiding from the war
came out and everybody twenty thousand
of them were gathering up the locust
they went to the king and said why
what's going on they said well because
usually a war only interest those who
started it well locust interest
everybody so they gather
because it's an important element of
food security and the recipes that we
documented in the literature are the
same today where you would gather up a
locust take off its wings stick it in a
pot and when it turns red like a shrimp
is ready to eat
or you can actually boil it put it in
the Sun to dry it grind it into a powder
because if it's more stable more compact
and they can travel with it and it
becomes a staple for the rest of the
year when they may not have rice or corn
to eat locust is like a staple you know
any for looking home keeper keeps locust
in their house because they need that
when there's times of lien and it's so
it's a safeguard and that's why it's
become a staple early explorers said wow
Madagascar is a place without famine
they can always eat the locust no that's
changed a lot there is a lot of famine I
wondered what we could do and when if we
could actually use this knowledge about
edible insects come up with a very
simple solution in a sense that blends
with their tradition to solve this
important problem of malnutrition which
is directly related to deforestation and
bush meat consumption in Madagascar so
we began some tests so our results show
that in Madagascar for example 70% of
people consume insects and that means
still there's 30% who don't they could
in their family decided it's what's
called a taboo it's a it's a call a
fatty so in their family they don't eat
insects or it could be that the whole
village doesn't do it so there are many
reasons why people don't but it's also
interesting why this is 70% do and when
do they do it
more and more we're finding that almost
all children consume insects but it's a
very hard thing to find out when you go
into a house and they're doing the
inventories about food consumption
they'll say basically what are you
eating and the kids aren't there the
parents are saying we're feeding them is
for feeding on this and there's no
insects but if you talk to the kids
did you eat insects they say no and then
you watch them when they're just
snacking on grasshoppers on the way to
school you're like hey wait a minute you
just said you don't need insects oh yeah
my mom doesn't give me insects but I eat
them all day long and we think actually
there might be an important element
being missing in the diets and maybe
that's the only protein they're getting
because when meat comes into the family
when bush meat comes in it's actually
almost always eaten by the men so the
women and children are not getting the
protein how are they living and this
could be one avenue in which they're
getting that protein and that also means
that if we give them the country the
bacon bud or other insects the kids will
get it and our results show that that X
actually is distributed to the people we
want to get you because if children
aren't eating when they go to school
they're not learning so if we want the
next game-changers come out of
Madagascar we want to give them hope and
the only way to do that is to actually
have smart Malagasy and you got to feed
them and I think insects is one way to
do it so we began to scour our knowledge
base of all the edible insects free
inventory to Madagascar and we realized
the best solution would be something
like the locusts that we could actually
grow grinding to UM powder that's stable
for maybe up to two years and ship it
across Madagascar and that's when we
reached out to Darren the cricket guy
Darren and his brothers Darren golden is
in charge of the largest producer of
cricket powder in North America and he
agreed to help us once we found a
candidate species that helped us deal up
a process to actually grow at a more
efficient and an effective rate crickets
in Madagascar but we need to find the
cricket so we turned to Sylva a cricket
expert in the region and we went out and
inventoried and started rearing
different species of native crickets to
figure out which one was okay to crowd
together which one that we could
actually feed something like grain and
we actually found a beautiful species
called gorillas Madagascar iNSYS and so
we had to actually test working with the
teams at intimal farms and silvana and
our local staff and train them and
develop and we figured out a protocol
now it's a six to seven week time span
in which it goes from egg to actually
adult and unlike all other
kind of farm processes we're harvesting
the cricket just at the end of their
life just when they finished laying eggs
just before they would die naturally we
would harvest them
we grind them up to make it more
efficient in the drying process in the
ovens and once they're dry we blend them
into a powder now we have a powder so
our research and others have shown that
25 grams of cricket powder is sufficient
for a daily dose each and for me every
morning I took a spoonful of cricket
powder and added to my yogurt it's like
sachet Ola it's actually has a chocolate
taste and it's actually fabulous
combination and that's how I eat it but
in Madagascar is usually added into a
sauce that's added to the rice it's a
very soft base culture and it's easy to
add that in in fact at certain times of
the year that's all they have so they
just add the cricket powder to water and
that's what's eaten we've recorded over
a hundred insect species that are eaten
in Madagascar but they're not eaten all
the time because they're only eaten when
they're present and that could be just
for a week or a month and what we want
to do is actually find the best
candidates for farming and then find a
way we can farm them all year round and
that's where the innovation comes in how
can we break the system so that they can
keep cycling and be abundant all year so
we are currently having our pilot farm
we call it that produces 30 kilos of
product a month then we want to change
that to be enormous because it's
scalable but at the same time it's a
quick response so for example if you got
hungry and then bought a baby cow you
have to wait a long time before you need
it but here if you just get some eggs
within six weeks you can be eating the
product so you have a very short
response time and the equipment required
to get going is very limited because
they don't require much water and much
feed for the conversion so what are we
going to do in Madagascar we want to
actually sell this product to different
groups like famine relief agencies but
to do that we had to get the fur
certification in Madagascar to actually
sell an edible insect product we were
lucky working with the Minister of
Health we were able to get a permit we
named our farm Valhalla farm showing the
Queen's palace there which is just above
our farm and we also got our process
certified by agency called into a trust
which is an international organisation
that means that our standards with our
health standards and our sustainability
standards are complete so we spent the
last two years learning how to grow with
less space more efficient get more
product for that effort and we started
producing on average about thirty kilos
of product a month now we have this
beautiful product we had to find you
know buyers the idea is if we could sell
this
we'd impact people but also be able to
use this funds to continue our research
and to expand our village programs
imagine if we could actually link
large-scale farming with our efforts in
the village while working with Catholic
Relief Services we started using our
product and family relief it was a
complement to the diet's to the meals
the food package is given to the 55,000
families in the South of Madagascar they
wanted a lot of product we couldn't
provide them a lot of product because at
the same time we started getting other
demands and really an interesting case
was tuberculosis clinic in the South
heard about it they also wanted our
product and they said all but we'll do
an experiment we'll give it to half the
people three times a week
and it just started working half the
people for the first time started to
gain weight and they started to have an
effect for the medicine they started to
get better in these types of
environments there's actually no
response for taking the medication
against TB because you're so already
deprived but they started getting better
so much better that the other half of
the people noticed and I said wait a
minute
we also want the pottery and there was a
strike and they refused to accept
another meal until they also got the
cricket putter
three days a week and then they said no
we wanted five days a week and this was
such a result
says that now they want to expand it to
10 clinics across Madagascar they aren't
having a product for that because we
also launched a program to feed
schoolchildren across the in the capital
in the poorest areas but it also has an
impact on the people we work with we're
providing jobs in fact we've made sure
that the whole process is really managed
and run by the Malagasy staff and that
means training like myself I didn't know
how to farm a cricket or a bacon bug
we went also and worked with the best
chefs of Madagascar to come up with
traditional recipes to integrate our
product into food and we're learning
together and it's really their
innovation their problem-solving on a
daily basis that's making as a success
now we were worried about maybe in the
urban sector we would have a different
perception but the children had no
problem but I also want you to note that
we also get something else
we get equal amount and weight
fertilizer so what fertilizer well
crickets do poop and that poop called
frass is a fantastic fertilizer we
initially thought our project would only
impact malnutrition and bush meat
consumption I didn't really appreciate
that we'd also produce an equal quantity
of fertilizer and this fertilizer is not
ordinary fertilizer
it's like magic stuff and elsewhere in
the world it's already being sold for
example the marijuana industry loves
this stuff and that kid is into maybe
there's something special about it so we
started using it in reforestation
projects and it's had a huge success
reforestation is a really difficult
subject it almost never works in
Madagascar we need all the help to
actually store even the tiniest amount
but somehow the crooked frass is
actually restoring the soil and that's
been key I think to why we're having
such a success but it's something also
that as we expand and create more and
more farms we can link reforestation or
improving the degraded landscapes around
these communities so that
they have more water they have more
resources it's a more holistic approach
to malnutrition we improve landscapes we
improve their health and it's that
togetherness that actually makes it work
so now we are hoping that we can
actually participate in the 60 million
tree plantation project that's happening
in Madagascar and here are some early
results that are super successful but
imagine if we could go into a village
and we could give them crickets and also
something for their local garden so
we've been designing small little
portable units that we could actually
bring into a town just a house just a
community and went they could farm a
small amount but and then use that
manure for fertilizer for their own
garden
well we've shown now that it's possible
we've shown that we can actually find
native species learn to farm them people
like them people benefit from it we have
to scale this up to meet the problem so
we wanted to actually create a much
larger farm and actually expand our
research to find more insects we could
farm in different areas of Madagascar so
we got the OK from the Minister of
Education they provided land for us
actually near our existing centre we've
designed it an hour actually fundraising
to build our first large-scale edible
insect center in Madagascar and that's
really part of our plan imagine going
across Madagascar linking large kind of
urban farming with local village
projects where we address the issues in
those villages through edible insects
maybe it's malnutrition
maybe it's against bush meat consumption
maybe it's soil erosion all this can be
addressed through edible insects it can
be small just one house it could be huge
you know a 30,000 square foot farm maybe
you feel a bit 'scrimish about eating
insects but I want to tell you at the
same time it's a booming industry in
fact you may have seen some of these
products well intimal farms isn't the
largest but there's others that
quickstart that makes a great bar
chips that makes great cookie dough and
chips but what this shows us is that
people are willing to try even in North
America ethos and it's actually an
industry that will continue to increase
as we ran out of other options for
increasing production of food and over
and over again I'll say this because it
tastes good
and that's why you'll be eating it soon
now this solution though is also
exciting because it involves an
incredible amount of science this has
been some of the best Nick most exciting
science I've done and I find out the
next day if we failed and this to me
makes me excited to be a scientist and
actually build it work on such an
important project but you may think well
that's nice what is it concerned me you
may be thinking well the ants get really
bad here aren't we going to Mars isn't
that's the solution well we already know
what you're gonna eat on Mars right
potatoes we've all seen the movie or the
book but you can't live on potatoes and
we know there's nothing to waste on Mars
so the only solution for food there will
be insects it's the most efficient
choice so why wait to Mars when it
should be starting this now this
pandemic we have right now has forced us
to rethink how we live everything about
our daily lives has changed this is the
time to make other personal choices
about how we want to come out of this
are we going to come out of this just
the same are we going to realize that
actually we can't be against mother
nature we have to be part of this we
can't fight the system by always taking
more and more of Earth we have to find a
way to actually be part of the system
and insects offer us a much safer avenue
of going forward if we want our society
to be any thing similar to what we have
now this is a great choice and I hope
that you can think through and if you
interested in participating in this
project we're still looking for exciting
people to help us carry this forward
and I look forward to hearing your
questions thank you thank you I want to
get this started I think Brian you
mentioned a few in a few places where
the Malagasy government have been
helping you but I just wanted to get a
sense of kind of the larger kind of
acceptance of this program and how
they're working with you on this or not
it's great to be part of a project that
has momentum and we don't even have to
tell people about this project in
Madagascar they come to us and for
somebody who's worked on insects before
that's striking we've have been
invisible ourselves for 30 years in
Madagascar but now it's getting noticed
because I think people see it as a as we
were told over and over again it's it's
a no-brain solution and it's something
they want to support and all fun I think
it's because they remember that they too
ate insects so it was the first time we
had actually introduced this as a
permitting process for the Minister of
Health but you know they were like oh
yeah
I insects so it must be good but let's
just go through the process and learn
how to do this together they were open
to it and that's what's been so exciting
and there's so many people involved if
from so many different sectors that it's
um it's it's an incredible synergy
that's taking this project forward
that's really great to hear and I know
that you I think you made a trip there
right as the quarantine was kind of
going into effect and I think got home
just on some of the last planes how how
was the pandemic affecting them and have
you heard since since being there well
it has impacted a few people they got
sickened in Madagascar but as a whole
they've been in one of the lucky
countries the countries where there
hasn't been a huge impact it's been
locked down so they're been very safe
but in the beginning it was quite a
shock to hear while we were there in a
very small village that the country was
closing and that there was a flight um
it was difficult because we were stuck
in a cyclone for five days with about a
metre of rain coming down in high winds
and to be honest that was more of a
concern
then thinking about trying to leave the
country but we made a a - and we were
luckily we got on the last flight out of
the country I didn't get very far I got
to Paris only but I did get out of the
country nice we have a question from one
of the live streams from Brad Perkins
what are the crickets being fed when
they're in the commercial farming
environments or all these bugs being fed
well that's a great question in fact
each each insect that we look at as
potential farming insect we have to
actually really understand what they
could eat
so the Sakuni for example that eats the
phloem of a plant so you don't feed it
feed or grain you actually give it a
plant to grow on and here we're using a
being a being that the sakuni
live off of but then when the beam
becomes mature people can harvest the
actual beans from it you know almost any
bean will work without the cricket in
nature it eats detritus or anything
that's decomposing now in the farm
environment we had to standardize it and
we first chose to standardize it on
spent millet because it's cheap and it's
an abundance if you're next to a brewery
it's the waste from a brewery so we
would you know order a ton of it at a
time and they would have it dumped off
and it'd be this pile of smelly millet
and we would feed it but as soon as we
started looking at experimentation to
improve yield experimentation to monitor
the impacts on nutrition we had to
standardize our feed so we have a simple
grain based feed right now and the
mixture is changing but it's a part corn
being sorghum and but it's wide open and
it's to me the biggest area of future
research because when you bring a mini
farm to a person a village or farm you
have to actually have already figured
out how you're going to feed them so
that could mean actually farming plants
too that go along with it so it's in
certain areas you have to think of the
picture what are you gonna feed them do
they have any vegetable waste most often
not so you're gonna have to actually
either be feeding them chicken feed or
actually growing plants to feed the
crickets nice I think you know I think
the obvious you know elephant in the
room is the you factor of insects and I
think you know one of the points that
that you speak about is you know really
you know we're eating prawns we're
eating lobsters we're eating we're
eating all these bugs from the sea and
they're actually you know some of our
greatest delicacies in many cases and we
somehow don't have an the same response
to that that we do I think in Western
culture at least two eating crickets I
just wonder if you could expand on that
and I know that you found that so much
of the world population is eating
insects and possibly vastly more than
even as being reported so I just if you
can talk a little bit more about how
those two things come together
all right so how to develop good habits
of eating insects well I would suggest
start off as a snack food you know it's
it's actually really tasty to eat that
and if they're already dead and in in in
a spicy maybe or vanilla or something
kind of sauce with it it's actually
you'll love it just as much as you like
snacking on Doritos it's that's your
thing it's actually quite quite
delicious and I think the hard part is
just to try it now maybe it'll be easier
if we just change the name we don't call
them insects anymore we call them land
shrimp and then that will help you get
over it but we don't actually have the
culture of of eating insects here but we
actually do have a culture of of trying
something new so I think just being
willing to try it once opens you up to
it and in Madagascar we I'm always
surprised that you know when we
introduced it there is our worry well
are they gonna eat it but that's never
been an issue like when you presented to
all 400 kids at the school the teachers
are like I don't know about this but no
kid says that
it's a learned it's a learned it's a
Linda every kid when they're you know
below the age of 13 I've eaten it but it
but I love that that's a country it's a
delicious bacon eat a stone you know if
that's you just you know I'm a type of
person who loves to snack when I write
or work so I I couldn't I prefer to eat
the country then uh right well yeah that
the idea of a bacon bug is definitely
you know converting me on that in a huge
way and I remember just being in Oaxaca
it wasn't until several days in that I
realized that the salts that I was
having with all of the the mezcal is a
cricket based this amazing cricket based
salt and those like all right well I
guess I'm eating insects and it kind of
it changed you know really the form
factor of powder and that change it you
know where it doesn't have legs and all
that and once you've done it you realize
it's delicious and and it's you know
it's it's as good as prawns really so we
have after this next question we're
going to bring in one of our founding
board members Kevin Kelly to ask a few
questions but I will I thought there's a
great question from Joe off of one of
our feeds and he's asking is it possible
to do this at home what is it how
complicated is a process of producing
the powder what are the resources for
this can we have an insect farm next to
our home garden if you can talk more
about that you could absolutely have a
cricket farm in your house you could
just buy a large clear container a big
tote and put in some egg cartons and go
out and collect some cricket eggs or buy
some online and start now you just have
to think about giving it a little bit of
water and giving it feed and you can buy
chicken feed easily online here and to
harvest them you can actually freeze
them to kill them you can then put them
in the oven to dry them and then you can
grind them in your coffee grinder or
your food grinder it's actually quite
easy and that is actually why it's a
useful solution the technology and the
simplicity allows it to scale the
simplicity of it also allows you to
bring in almost any
community when you walk away you have to
make sure they're still going to carry
on and use it it has to be that simple
and it has to be viewed also as part of
their tradition it's not part of our
tradition but in Madagascar it is part
of their tradition like it is in Mexico
New Mexico they eat over 500 species of
insects we've documented only over a
hundred or so in Madagascar but it's a
really important part of the culture
even today yeah well it's a lot less
terrifying than trying to raise and
butcher and slaughter a pig or something
like that in your home garden I think
that's that it's it's a much more
reasonable thing to be doing home
protein creation with bugs then than
doing it with you know large animals
when you go on vacation you can just
harvest them all before you leave
eat them right start over anybody I know
who has animals like the going on
vacation is actually the most difficult
thing that they could possibly imagine
yeah that's a great point
yeah okay so we're gonna bring in Kevin
Kelly who's been filtering some of your
questions to me and he has a few
questions of his own welcome Kevin
yes I'm wondering what you have learned
from the experience in Mexico because as
you noted there is a very long tradition
of eating insects in Mexico and they may
have maybe modernized it or evolve dydt
and was there anything that you learned
about how Mexico does insect eating well
they have helped a lot in diversifying
the recipes of the potential of it and
that's really important it's it's really
some really sophisticated cuisine level
aspects of it which can be borrowed and
you reuse in many ways but there isn't
an exact translation from Madagascar in
Madagascar we wanted to make sure people
there thought of it as their traditions
that were augmenting and expanding so we
wanted to make sure we're using the
native species in Madagascar it would
have been a lot simpler to go and take a
species they've already farmed in Mexico
bring it to Madagascar and farm it there
but then it wouldn't be Malagasy
and also we'd be introducing a species
and we wanted to make sure we had a
native species so that's where the
research came in and it's been fun
actually to learn about all these
different insects and their taste
differences and that's also exciting you
know we've researched chickens for 80
years about how to grow them and so
forth and here we are we're in we're
bringing new food groups you know food
animals and cultivation and that's
really exciting and it's diversifying
the food systems also in Mexico they
already in a sense had partitioned
insects into their diets at a certain
level traditionally and it really hasn't
changed much and what we wanted to do in
Madagascar is actually fill an enormous
gap in in their society don't forget
there's a big difference being in terms
of malnutrition and poverty between
Mexico and Madagascar so I think the
need for this solution is greatest in
places like Madagascar and because it
combines her tradition and their
solution in one area so we've done
breeding in the past for that food
animals and have greatly increased their
efficiency and even taste through
greetings so is there any kind of
programs to breed either new varieties
of insects or new forms of insects or
even GM is generally modified insects
that were actually engineered just for
food in terms of insects yes I think
every farm is actually modifying their
genetics right we're selecting we're
selecting insects that meet our criteria
that we harvest them in seven weeks that
they're laying eggs at a certain time so
we're actually selecting but our initial
stalk just two years ago was collected
in the wild around the capital city but
this species was never farmed before so
it's actually a new species but there is
a giant industry which is kind of
different for producing edible insects
for mass consumption and that's like for
example intima farms and there's a more
and more of them around the world now
and and they use a very limited set of
species that they're farming it could be
the mealworm or the one cricket that
most of these other farmers are using
and they're also are not spending as
much time on the genetics part but
they're the Technic side most of the
gains are in the efficiencies of
managing the actual farming process I
think in maybe five years they'll start
selecting special strains to go forward
but right now there's so much efficiency
gains just on simple changing parameters
of how you feed them um
what temperature what humidity and what
feed so those are the gains right now
and you mention the insects are
particularly efficient food converters
because they're they're eating plants
farm raised plants and converting it
into protein and so animals do that fish
seafood do it and insects do it too why
are insects so much more efficient
they're more efficient because they're
not wasting it on heating the body all
the the the the cows the pigs the
chickens the the vertebrates they're
spending a lot of energy on keeping
their body warm so when you give them
food they have to spend a lot of it on
keeping their body warm and keeping
their body cool and that requires a lot
more water so it takes a lot more water
in for cows six times as much food to
generate the same amount of protein and
now that's just protein and the insects
because wheat the whole thing it's more
efficient because we're not plucking all
the feathers out we're not throwing away
the bones we're actually eating the
entire insect at the end of its life
which has which is an advantage death
eclis so it's a couple of questions from
some of the other people online rachel
kusik i think that's how you pronounce
it says i'm what do you need to scale
this across Madagascar what's the gating
hurdle that you need is it investment
money is it adoption what
what what is the biggest hurdle right
now to scale us up into in terms of what
you can imagine it well I think this is
the exciting part of it that we have
learned how to scale our pilot project
has showed us that we know how to farm
the crickets we know we can we can feed
them we know how to do it at any scale
and I think what we're trying to do
right now is create our first center of
research and farm our first large-scale
farm to help us address in particular
bush meat consumption and famine in
madagascar malnutrition so we've set
down this path of building up this farm
and we're fundraising for it now in fact
it's only through supporters and donors
have we've gotten this far and we hope
that we can actually raise the necessary
capital to actually build it in fact our
construction plans are out to tender
right now but we still have to fundraise
a lot about 750 fifty thousand dollars
actually to finish the building okay
this is Stuart brand who's watching
online has a question is could insects
be an intermediate way of increasing the
yield of chickens chickens love to eat
insects so could you take feed make
insects and then feed those two chickens
with that improve the yield event of
chicken or would yield the environmental
or diminish the environmental impact any
by having the intermediate of feed to
trick it to insects chickens there are
many people that love to raise chickens
or or see that as a solution for a lot
of a lot of problems and it's true that
there are some advantages people are to
eat chickens and you can actually sell
their eggs and we've seen data that
suggests that if you actually feed
cricket powder or crickets whole
crickets to chickens they can even
double their egg-laying production so
the the chickens are doing better but
you still have to feed the crickets just
like you would have to feed the chickens
and whether or not you think it's better
to have that product go to a human
versus a chicken is is is a question III
do see that there is an existing chicken
industry so if you just look at that and
say how can we help that industry I
agree I think there are gains to be made
in terms of the impact of the current
chicken industry if you actually use
cricket food instead of seafood for
example to feed the chickens so here's
another online question from Nicholas
Bruce ace Bruce a whisk and it's do
edible insects get or spread disease the
way that livestock does is is is this
another reason to adopt insects because
perhaps they don't transmit geologically
powerful diseases that is an excellent
question and there are no known diseases
that could be transmitted by eating a
dead cooked insect unlike we know they
exist for cows for example mad cow
disease for example in addition there's
another incredible advantage is that if
you actually cook a steak you can't keep
it in the cupboard cupboard for two
years and and bring it out when you're
have a moment of hunger but you can do
that to ground cricket powder for
example once it's dried its stable you
can easily transport it around and you
can store it as a ration to be available
when you actually need it and that's a
huge advantage it doesn't go bad okay I
have a question your totem animal is an
ant
so are ants good eating as well do they
taste good and do they make any sense to
try and eat ants well Hymenoptera were
ants bees and wasps belong you often
don't eat the adult the larvae though
are quite tasty in Mexico escamole is
the larvae the babies of ants
and so yes you can't eat the larvae but
you have to get a lot of it he had to
find it you know dig up a nest and or
find it access to it they're really hard
to farm so I don't just farming them in
Madagascar we were I was surprised to
learn that they actually harvest a lot
of wasp larvae and the fact they've
started exporting it few years ago they
exported nine tons to reunion of wasp
larvae you know you've heard about this
great murderous loss that's going to
invade North America just think of the
larvae we could get out of it
maybe it's could be interesting to farm
the big murderous wasp that's always the
solution for invasive species is just
turn them into food and then people will
eliminate them very quickly some several
questions one from Rona Rene about
whether the weather insects would how
that compares to a virgin diet in terms
of its environmental impact and it wears
just like our insects close enough to
plants in terms of their footprint their
carbon footprint in terms of this whole
system or is does the fact that they're
still you're still farming feed not
really diminish that very much in terms
of an animal insects are the most
sustainable food source there is without
a doubt of course if you just eat plants
that's that's even better but this is
the best solution for animal protein is
eating insects and as I mentioned before
you know it's not eating the chicken in
its prime in its youth or a cow it's
actually harvesting the crickets at the
end of their lives so we actually have
timed it such that we want to harvest
just before they would die naturally
about two days before they would die we
would harvest them
so it's at the end of their life and I
think that's also very important and
when you think about what we're eating
you know I remember a time when fish
farming was seen as a solution and of
course now the scale that fish farming
is done particularly in Asia it's become
a problem what kind of problems would
there be in farming insects if this was
really successful well there's two
angles like an answer that question one
would be in Madagascar right now
because we're operating as an NGO and
not as a business per se we can direct
all the impacts to the people and the
forest that means we can choose our
local villages where we work where we
can impact bush meat consumption we can
choose where our impacts are going in
terms of the price points that we can
actually address famine and malnutrition
however it when it becomes a business it
would simply be oh we just want to
actually grow crickets in Madagascar to
export for the world market and that's
when I think it becomes only interesting
in terms of the business model rather
than the impact for the people so the
advantage of right now the situation in
Madagascar if we are able to expand now
we can actually impact people and in a
sense democratize access for protein at
the international and investment right
now in edible insects it's great to have
all corners of of where we can have
impact in the world expand and I think
investment is required for that but we
want to make sure no matter what happens
in Madagascar as we expand we can
actually ensure that the impacts are
staying for the Malagasy people so what
can individuals in the u.s. do to
support this exciting adventure into a
new kind of farming a new car
of food source
I could imagine culinary adventurous I
could imagine
farming experiments what would you
suggest people do to further this
initiative dishes is exciting in a sense
that it impacts it's so many different
angles if you're interested in lemurs
you could be interested in the Bushmen
impacts you if you're interested in
children you could be interested in in
their actual impacts if you're in
nutrition or health related fields you
can look at the impacts on the actual
growth and and nutrition if you're
interested in reforestation you could be
looking at how and why cricket frass is
so effective at improving growth in
plants and not just for the first year
but there's a residual that impacts year
after year why is that there are so many
exciting questions to look at and also
in terms of just the analysis of the
models of this idea of feeding crickets
to chickens
is it worth it does what do we gain from
that versus choosing another choice what
are the issues of scaling there's this
model such that we've created such an
interest in it that we can't even
actually feed the people in Madagascar
anymore because the markets are driving
us to sell outside of market outside of
Madagascar so I think there's plenty of
room for diverse backgrounds to to go
into this or you could say hey we want
to actually make the most efficient
building in Madagascar for cricket
farming helped us design it there's many
avenues to bring you into this project
well well thank you I'm gonna hand the
baton back to Zander who has some more
questions himself Hey thank you Kevin
that was really great I mean I think we
don't have that much more here but I
think I would really love to kind of
understand you know what is the kind of
economic loop that you have going with
the product that you're creating now is
it is it in kind of beta are you
and I realized that part of this is that
you're raising some money around this
project so I want to make sure that we
talk about where you are in that phase
of building the economic model and and
also some of your fundraising efforts
that are around this right so our model
is based on that there's a need in
Madagascar for famine and malnutrition
relief there's international food
agencies that import protein to
Madagascar to feed the famine areas and
kovat has only made this worse in
Madagascar right now there's never been
such a need for example in the south of
Madagascar for improving the nutrition
especially of children or 50% or
malnourished and I repeat this again
there cannot be hope in Madagascar
unless you have kids in school that have
eaten and they're learning and they're
becoming the next solution themselves
for the country we need to invest in
that there's not a quick answer but one
of the answers is nutrition so we want
to actually sell our product to that
international food relief agencies we're
doing it now we created a need for it
but we're only meeting about 10% of that
need right now and we expect we can make
that need expand to more and more food
relief agencies in Madagascar and in
Africa so once we have finished
expanding across Madagascar we hope to
also expand this idea this model into
Africa but to do that step one is to
actually produce our first large-scale
farm that could feed about 55,000
children a year and how many like
roughly like how many pounds of stuff is
that what we can work it out better
that's it's about 600 meals at 25 grams
each that would be produced by this one
farm that's what's produced by this one
farm of about 3,000 square metres that's
a research lab and that and
we you know one option would be to take
investments and become like the other
cricket farmers around the world for
example but we want to actually do
something different where we're actually
are developing new species in Madagascar
to solve solutions or solve problems in
different areas of Madagascar in the
South of Madagascar that's where the
famine is but that's where they also are
eating this incredible land turtle
they're the tortoise that's just
beautiful and what if we could actually
use cricket farming to prevent them from
eating that endangered tortoise there
that's a solution that requires a new
species not the species we have in a
capital but a species that can grow in
the hot desert of the south of
Madagascar Matt takes research we want
to be basically the innovators the
problems solvers and then after this we
hope that we can actually include
investors to help us expand to different
areas but this first large-scale farm
and center I think has to be in a sense
managed without that type of investment
and is there a way for outside people to
help you and in these endeavors yes if
they're interested in helping us through
fundraising they can donate toward the
California Academy of Sciences our local
great San Francisco Museum which I think
this project really highlights the role
of museums now and combining their
history of science with current problem
solving and our museum is leading the
campaign to actually raise the funds for
this new and only Center that exists in
the world really dedicated to this type
of research cool well thank you so much
we'll make sure that we share the
correct links on on the feeds and I
think this is clearly an important
project that's changing the way the
protein is both created and and consumed
around the world and it's but it's just
really great to see you and to be out of
the house once again and hanging out
with real people so
thank you all who have joined us on the
feed and I hope that you enjoyed
tonight's talk and we can't wait to see
you at the next one thank you very much
[Music]